Heute im Rasenfunk.
Alexander Schur, das ist ein Märchen, ein unglaubliches Märchen. Der Frankfurter schießt Eintracht Frankfurt in die Bundesliga.
Langhals fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor und Augsburg ist open. Schluss vorbei aus der SSV Ulm, das A- und P-Team steht für attraktiv und preiswert in der Bundesliga. Und jetzt ist das letzte Kapitel im verrücktesten Fußballmärchen der Saison geschrieben.
Also mich bringt nichts mehr so in Zweitligastimmung wie dieses Intro. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schön, dass ihr den Rasenfunk eingeschaltet habt. Das hier ist die Ligatur. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Und wie immer habe ich drei fantastische Gäste. Ich freue mich sehr, einen alten Bekannten des Rasenfunks hier zu begrüßen. Kevin Bublitz ist da vom Padercast, also hallo Kevin. Ja, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist. Außerdem auch schon hier alt bekannt. Ich bekomme immer noch Rückmeldungen zu unserem Tribüngespräch von Anno Dazumal, Sebastian, als wir eigentlich die Frage gestellt haben, wie ist der FCK dahingekommen, wo er jetzt ist, also finanziell gesehen. Es ist aber immer gute Rückmeldungen. Hallo Sebastian Zobel vom SWR und dem Nur der FCK-Podcast. Hi Sebastian.
Das werden wir dann sehen. Und jetzt haben wir auch schon die perfekte Brücke, um über den ersten FC Kaiserslautern zu sprechen. Denn da ist es ja nicht so, dass festgehalten wurde am Trainer. Und das musst du mir jetzt als allererstes mal erklären, Sebastian. Also, Dimitrius Kramotsis ist jetzt Trainer. Er hat auch insofern einen erfolgreichen Einstieg gehabt, als man jetzt im DFB-Pokal gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg weitergekommen ist. Also man steht im Viertelfinale sowieso. DFB-Pokal, aktuell Geisterwettbewerb. Schaut euch die Viertelfinalisten an. Nehmen auch irgendwie die paar Erstligisten raus. Und wir haben nur noch Spaß alle. Also es ist ja absolut fantastisch. Aber erklär mir mal bitte, Sebastian, warum musste Dirk Schuster gehen? Denn von der Tabellenkonstellation her, bis auf die Niederlagenserie am Schluss, konnte man das nicht nachvollziehen von außen.
Ich habe das vorhin durchaus ernst gemeint, als ich gesagt habe, dass dieses Düsseldorf-Spiel, glaube ich, wirklich entscheidend war. Weil du zum einen einfach einen extremen moralischen Tiefschlag hattest, nachdem du nach so einer stabilen Führung dieses Spiel noch verlierst. Zum anderen diese ganze Geschichte drumherum mit diesem Flaschenwurf noch. Und dann verletzt sich ein Ragnar Acher, der wirklich in Lautern eingeschlagen hat, wie eine Bombe. Also das sind wirklich auch so ein paar Spieler, wo Thomas Hengen, der Sportchef oder der Hauptvereinsboss, ein echt glückliches Händchen bewiesen hat, die in Lautern plötzlich, warum auch immer, funktionieren. Richmond sagt liebe Grüße.
Ja, aber den Ragnar Ache, habe ich im Sommer gesagt, soll der Markus Koschke Felix aus Frankfurt nach Paderborn schicken, in seine Heimat und nicht zu euch, obwohl er gelandet bei euch ist.
Wir waren auch daneben dran, glaube ich. Man fragt sich wirklich, warum ein Spieler mit der Qualität sich für Lautern entscheidet, aber offenbar hatten sie gute Argumente, ihn zu überzeugen, dass er da was aufbauen kann. Ich glaube, er zahlt es zurück, dass man ihm einfach dieses Vertrauen schenkt und ihn machen lässt. Du hast dann dieses Spiel verloren, du hast deinen Topscorer verloren und du hast wirklich gemerkt, auch wenn natürlich die Verantwortlichen das immer dann bestritten haben, da gab es einfach einen Bruch. Dann gab es danach noch dieses HSV-Spiel, wo du auch eine stabile Führung aus der Hand gibst, das zwar dann nicht verlierst, aber unentschieden spielst. Das waren so zwei Spiele, das hat dann einfach keiner mehr verstanden, wie das sein kann, dass du zwei so deutliche Führungen aus der Hand gibst. Ab dann hat die Formkurve nach unten gezeigt. Die Saison hat mit zwei Niederlagen begonnen. Da hat man schon gewusst, okay, könnte schwierig werden, aber da war es so, das erste Spiel ging direkt gegen Pauli verloren, da war noch so, mal gucken. Aber jetzt sieht man ja, wo Pauli steht. Von daher war als Gradmesser damals schon, okay, kann man irgendwie nachvollziehen. War jetzt auch nicht so, dass man da unterirdisch gespielt hat. Dann hat man auf Schalke verloren, wo man sagen muss, da hat man sich unnötig in Rückstand gebracht, durch rote Karten auch. Hat aber an sich ein spielerisch gutes Spiel gemacht und eigentlich auch in der Höhe unverdient verloren. Also ich sage mal, die Niederlage geht am Ende in Ordnung, aber man hat sich da eigentlich gut verkauft. Und ab dann, ab dem dritten Spieltag, ging es dann wirklich bergauf. Man hat eine Serie gestartet und die Mannschaft hat wirklich, also wirklich entfesselt auch gespielt, hat spielerisch geglänzt, gerade im Offensivbereich. Bis eben zu diesem Düsseldorf-Spiel, wo man auch, da gebe ich Thorsten recht, da hat man sich auch gefragt, was ist denn hier los? Wie kann es denn jetzt hier 3-0 für den SCK stehen? Geht ja gar nicht. Also vom Spielverlauf her war er durch, also auch glücklich. Ja, und dann hätte man aber eigentlich auch gedacht, oder hätte ich auch gedacht, dass die Dirk Schuster noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit geben. Weil es schon so ist in Lautern, wie es, glaube ich, bei vielen Vereinen auch ist. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe auch jetzt bei der Pressekonferenz, als dann Thomas Heng da vor uns Journalisten saß und die Gründe dann erklärt hat, warum man sich von Dirk Schuster getrennt hat, habe ich auch gesagt, wir saßen jetzt hier in den letzten Jahren so oft und es wurde uns was erzählt von, man möchte eine Spielphilosophie entwickeln, man braucht eine gewisse Kontinuität. Und dann habe ich auch mal gefragt, wie sieht es denn aus? Woran hängt das denn, dass hier niemand die Zeit hat, mal was zu entwickeln, oder dass das einfach nicht funktioniert, dass hier mal wirklich mal jemand länger als anderthalb Jahre da ist und die Chance hat, was zu entwickeln? Und andere Vereine, jetzt haben wir gerade über Paderborn gesprochen, da hält man dran fest und versucht dem Trainer wirklich Zeit zu geben, was zu entwickeln und klar, die Beispiele, die dann immer kommen, mit Heidenheim und Freiburg, aber ich finde es auch einfach mal spannend, zu sehen, was dabei rauskommt, wenn jemand längere Zeit was entwickeln kann. Und ich muss sagen, das ist jetzt auch nicht so, es gibt immer ein gespaltenes Lager, es gibt immer Leute, die sagen, der Trainer muss weg, ist immer der Erste, der weg muss. Und es gab tatsächlich, und da sind wir auch wieder bei Elbersberg, Lautern hat ja auch 2-1 hinten gelegen beim Heimspiel gegen Elbersberg, da gab es die ersten schuste Rausrufe damals. Dann hat der FCK das Spiel aber noch gedreht, da waren alle wieder happy. Und dann ist es auch, also meiner Meinung nach, hat der Schuster es auch wirklich geschafft, man hat gesehen, er hat die Mannschaft weiterentwickelt, er konnte die vielen Neuzugänge gut einbauen. Klar, die Defensive war und ist das große Manko, man hat es jetzt im Pokal zum ersten Mal geschafft, diese Saison überhaupt keinen Tor zu fangen, was eigentlich unglaublich ist. Aber es war jetzt nicht so, dass man das Gefühl hatte, da geht gar nichts mehr, aber es war dann wirklich auch so, der FCK hatte dann auch diese extreme englische Woche mit drei Spielen, mit dem Pokalspiel, mit Köln dazwischen, da gab es drei Heimspiele, HSV, dann das Pokalspiel gegen Köln und dann Gräuter Fürth daheim, innerhalb von einer Woche drei Heimspiele, wo man eigentlich denkt, auch so als die Fans, was kann es geileres geben, als innerhalb von einer Woche dreimal zu spielen, davon einmal gegen HSV und einmal gegen den 1. FC Köln, sorry Fürth, aber das waren zwei Spiele, da sind innerhalb von drei Spielen über 120.000 Leute auf den Betzenberg gekommen, zweimal ausverkauft und selbst gegen Fürth auch über 40.000. Das zeigt auch schon, was Dirk Schuster mit der Mannschaft ja auch geschafft hat, nämlich er hat eine unglaubliche Euphorie auch wiederentwickelt. Das ging letzte Saison, in der ersten Saison nach dem Wiederaufstieg aus der dritten Liga los, die Leute hatten wieder Lust, das Feuer ist wieder entfacht. Du hast wirklich gemerkt, wer mal versucht hat, als Otto Normal Mensch eine Karte für ein FCK-Spiel zu bekommen, der guckt ganz schön schnell in die Röhre bei Auswärtsspielen genauso. Da wird immer das komplette Kontingent plus abgerufen. Es ist Wahnsinn, was die Fans da abreißen.
Ihr wart auch letzte Saison beim Heimspiel bei uns. Da wart ihr wirklich auch neben dem HSV mit der größten Menge an Zuschauern vertreten. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele es waren, aber natürlich auch weit über den Auswärtsblock hinaus.
Ich frage mich da auch immer, wer das genau dann zählt und schätzt, wenn es dann heißt 10.000 oder HSV bei Hertha mit 20.000. Aber es sind auf jeden Fall viele. Jedenfalls lief eigentlich alles sehr, sehr gut. Und dann kam dieser Bruch nach Düsseldorf. Und dann war es auch wirklich unerklärlich, dass die Mannschaft dann teilweise völlig neben sich stand. Es ist nichts mehr zusammengelaufen. Und da muss man halt dann sagen, durch diese Konstante, die du vorne mit Ragnar Ache am Anfang der Saison hattest, das ist wirklich ein Spieler. Ich habe noch selten einen, vor allem in der 2. Liga, einen Spieler gesehen, der jedes Kopfball-Duell gewinnt. Also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, wann Ragnar Ache ein Kopfball-Duell verloren hat. Der steht in der Luft. Und das ist einfach diese physische Präsenz, die der hat, seine Schnelligkeit, sein Antritt, seine Luftstärke. Wahnsinn. Dann fiel der weg. Dann hattest du immer noch einen Terence Boyd, der jetzt wirklich auch kein Unbekannter ist, der auch ein Super-Standing hat bei den Fans, der es natürlich aber schwer hatte, war dann nicht fit. Dann kam Ache, und dann ist es halt einfach schwer. Und die beiden zusammen gingen dann zwar zwischenzeitlich auch mal kurz, aber es sind eigentlich keine zwei Spielertypen, die du zusammenstellen kannst. Das würden die meisten Trainer wahrscheinlich nicht machen. Dann hat Terence Boyd die Chance quasi wieder bekommen, als Ache dann verletzt war. Und dann war es halt einfach brutal schwer. Dann war der FCK in einer Situation, wo er jetzt nicht gerade aus dem Vollen schöpfen konnte, was Chancen anging. Und dann muss halt auch Terence Boyd aus den wenigen Chancen, die er dann kriegt, mal was machen, hat er dann nicht geschafft. Dementsprechend hattest du dann keine Konstante mehr im Angriff. Und dann war es einfach echt schwierig. Aber es hat uns, um das jetzt mal abzurunden, es hat uns alle, auch die Journalisten-Kollegen und mich, sehr überrascht. Der Zeitpunkt war auch komisch, so mitten in der Woche, wo du gesagt hast, eigentlich hättest du dich direkt nach dem vorangegangenen Spiel trennen können, anfangs der Woche, an einem Montag. Aber dann ist das irgendwie so mitten in der Woche, trennst du dich dann, hast dann quasi kaum noch Zeit für das nächste Spiel in Magdeburg. Trittst dann da mit einem Interimsteam an und stellst dann am nächsten Tag den Trainer vor. Der hat dann zwei Tage, sich aufs Pokalspiel vorzubereiten. Also es war schon irre. Und man muss auch sagen, Dimitrios Komotzis hat jetzt einen guten Einstand gehabt. Aber man muss es so deutlich ansprechen, es kann eigentlich nicht so sein, dass Dimitrios Komotzis die 1A-Lösung war. Es sind ja viele Namen gehandelt worden. Die Kollegen vom Kicker hatten ja auch berichtet, dass man sich mit Herrn Wimmer sehr einig war. Es läuft alles darauf raus, dass es nur der Plan gewesen sein kann, dass man Wimmer verpflichten wollte, dass dann aber eben zu früh an die Öffentlichkeit ging und man dann quasi handeln musste. Weil wenn dann mal auf dem Markt ist, dass man sich mit anderen Trainern unterhält, dann kann man natürlich den eigenen Coach schon noch schwer halten. Aber das war einfach alles in allem eine schwierige Situation und passt auch eigentlich nicht zu den Dingen, wobei doch eigentlich passt es doch zu Thomas Hengen, weil er hat ja auch damals kurz vor der Relegation zu den Aufstiegsspielen in die 2. Liga auch die Trainerentscheidung damals getroffen, Marco Antwerpen entlassen und Dirk Schuster geholt. Und der Erfolg hat ihm recht gegeben. Von daher hat er jetzt wieder unkonventionell gehandelt.
Ja, vor allem, was heißt unkonventionell? Also in Lautern am Marstein war das ja wieder Textbook-Lautern. Das ist ja 60 Lautern, Schalke, HSV. Warum macht ihr immer die... Also, ich meine, du hast es ja selber noch mal super rausgearbeitet. Aber ich möchte das noch mal kurz unterstreichen. Als man gegen Düsseldorf dieses Spiel hatte, bei dem man den Bruch hatte, da lag man auf dem dritten Tabellenplatz. Das war am zehnten Spieltag. Als man dann gegen den HSV nur 3 zu 3 gespielt hat als Lautern. Man ist ja immer noch Lautern, es tut mir leid. Da lag man danach immer noch auf dem sechsten Tabellenplatz. Und klar, es wurde dann schlechter. Aber das Schlimme ist doch, wenn du nicht sagen kannst, woran es liegt. Wenn du aber sagen kannst, uns fehlt ein richtig guter Stürmer. Der ist von einer Flasche getroffen worden. Der musste ausgewechselt werden. Mega dumm gelaufen. Ist nicht von einer Flasche getroffen worden?
Doch, er ist von einer Flasche getroffen worden.
Aber das war nicht der Grund für die Auswechslung.
Er hat weitergespielt, er wurde gefragt, ob er weiterspielen will. Da kann man dann auch die Frage stellen, wie verantwortungsvoll war das, den weiterspielen zu lassen. Der hat danach auch recht benommen gewirkt. Aber du wolltest noch was anderes.
Kopfverletzungen im Fußball, genau.
Das ist jetzt nochmal dein Lieblingsthema. Nachwanken.
Das finde ich schon schön, dass Leute hier als Gastgeschenk ihre Flankenstatistik ihres Vereins mitbringen. Danke nochmal, Thorsten. Aber man kann es ja sogar begründen, woran es liegt. Ich kann gerade gar nicht glauben, dass ich ein Plädoyer für Dirk Schuster halte. Ich habe seinen Fußball nie gerne gesehen. Und der Abgang beim FC Augsburg damals war spektakulär. In all seinen Facetten. Aber dennoch will mir das nicht in den Kopf, warum das Lautern so macht. Und warum ich dann auch tatsächlich in Teilen der Berichterstattung, ich habe das alles nur quasi lesen können, was da bei Lautern passiert. Zu viele andere Themen nebenher noch. Und da klang das in vielen Berichten so, ja, naja, irgendwie konnte man es jetzt schon fast erwarten. Lief jetzt nicht so für Schuster. Und ich denke mir so, ja, aber ihr seid doch im 2. Zweitliga-Jahr.
Ja, übrigens, als du vorhin aufgezählt hast, wie gut es lief, nach dem Sieg gegen Hannover, war man sogar über Nacht mal Tabellenführer. Und jetzt kann man sich anschauen, wo der FCK mittlerweile steht. Ich gebe dir da vollkommen recht. Ich glaube, dass man mittlerweile oder das Teile der Fans und vielleicht auch gewisse Leute im Hintergrund des Vereins vielleicht vergessen haben, wo man eigentlich herkommt. Die Sache ist die, es wird so oft zitiert, das zweite Jahr nach Wiederaufstieg ist das Schwerste. Im ersten ist man von der Euphorie getragen worden gerade in der Hinrunde. Und dann, wie es in der Rückrunde schlecht war, aber egal, hat am Ende trotzdem noch locker gereicht. Jetzt bist du in dem zweiten Jahr und musst eigentlich dich dran erinnern, wo kommst du her. Und nichts anderes als der Klassenerhalt kann eigentlich das Ziel sein. Aber natürlich ist es so, das war in der letzten Saison schon so, da hat die Mannschaft in der Hinrunde overperformed. Das weckt natürlich Hoffnung. Gerade bei den Menschen in Kaiserslautern, ich habe das in jedem Podcast, auch immer, wenn ich bei dir bin, Max, rede ich das, glaube ich, hoch und runter. Diese Erwartungshaltung, dieses wo kommt man her? Die Leute kennen das noch. Die Leute kennen die goldenen 90er Jahre. Der FCK ist mehrfacher deutscher Meister und Pokalsieger. Die Leute haben natürlich irgendwo den Anspruch, irgendwann wieder Bundesliga zu spielen. Und vielleicht gibt es da doch auch ein paar Leute, auch ein paar Fußball-Experten, die sagen, vielleicht doch irgendwann gehört der FCK da auch mal wieder hin.
Das wäre ja auch geil, wenn der FCK da spielen würde.
Man muss sich aber bewusst machen, wo man herkommt. Man kommt aus ganz, ganz bitteren Drittliga-Jahren, die den Verein fast zerstört haben. Der FCK stand wirklich kurz vor dem Aus. Du hast vorhin unser Tribütengespräch angesprochen. Thema Insolvenz und so weiter. Also es war wirklich so kurz davor, dass dieser Verein nicht mehr existiert hätte. Oder in der Form nicht mehr existiert hätte. Von daher kann man wirklich nur sagen, Leute, haltet den Ball flach. Auch wenn die Mannschaft durch ihre Spielweise jetzt auch diese Hinrunde zum Teil wieder natürlich Begehrlichkeit geweckt hat. Und ich glaube einfach, dass dann vielleicht im Hintergrund auch Investoren, Sponsoren stehen, die natürlich sagen, sie geben da jede Menge Geld rein. Und sie wollen, was ja irgendwo auch verständlich ist, wenn ich irgendwo so viel Geld investieren würde, würde ich es wahrscheinlich genauso machen oder erwarten. Die wollen natürlich Erfolge sehen. Und die wollen sehen, dass man dann irgendwann doch halt hochgeht und dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das dann auch dazu führt, dass man sagt, ja, probieren wir es doch nochmal mit einem anderen Trainer, weil es ist halt einfacher, die arme Sau an der Seitenlinie auszutauschen als die ganze Mannschaft.
Da gibt es sicherlich unterschiedliche Lager, oder? Es gibt ja, bei den einen könnte man auch von Träumen sprechen.
Ja, natürlich.
Und gerade bei Fans, wie du es sagst, ist das, das kann ich auch voll nachvollziehen, das ist ja sogar ein Paderborn jetzt so. Bei uns wurde am zweiten Spieltag die Mannschaft ausgefiffen. Beim ersten Heimspiel. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Der SC Paderborn ist finanziell eine der schlecht gebettetsten Mannschaften im Profifußball. Aber ich kann trotzdem natürlich verstehen, wenn man so Jahre hat, wo man dann begeisternden Fußball spielt, also Aufstiegssaison, dann erste Saison und so, dann sind die Fans natürlich auch schnell, dass sie das vielleicht nicht vergessen, aber dass sie halt einfach sagen, boah, geil, das läuft jetzt wirklich gut. Dann wirst du süchtig nach diesen. Ich hab das auch erlebt. Das 1-0 gegen Hannover war so langweilig phasenweise, wo ich gedacht hab, wo ist denn dieser geile Offensivspektakel, dieses Offensivspektakel, was uns jetzt über Jahre ausgemacht hat?
Träumen ist ja auch erlaubt. Und gerade beim Fußball. Also das ist doch das... Kleine Kinder gehen zum ersten Mal ins Stadion, die Augen leuchten und die träumen dann davon, dass die auch irgendwann da auf dem Rasen stehen. Und genauso träumen die Fans davon, dass ihre Mannschaft irgendwann...
Natürlich, du willst nicht...
Es tut mir leid, du willst nicht gegen Kräuter Fürth spielen. Du willst nicht so gut, wie wir sie jetzt hochgeredet haben, du willst nicht gegen Elbersberg spielen, du willst gegen Bayern München... Natürlich wollen die Leute gegen Bayern München spielen. Weil einfach, das ist das. Wir haben eine Generation von Kindern, man kann immer drüber scherzen, es gibt eine Generation von Kindern, die haben seit 10 Jahren keinen anderen Meister gesehen als Bayern. Es gibt eine ganz große Generation von Kindern, die haben den FCK noch nie Bundesligaspielen gesehen, bzw. sehen ihn jetzt zum ersten Mal überhaupt 2. Liga spielen. Aber die kriegen immer erzählt. Vom Papa, vom Opa, vom Onkel, von der Familie. Na, wie war das damals, als wir die Bayern geschlagen haben, als wir deutscher Meister waren? Und hier Fritz Walter, der Beste aller Zeiten. Natürlich, das ist einfach auch eine unglaubliche Bürde, diese erfolgreiche Vergangenheit. Das habe ich auch schon gebetsmühlenartig oft erzählt in Podcasts. Es ist super, es ist wahnsinnig spannend und toll, dass der Verein diese bewegende Geschichte hat. Das habe ich, habe mich gerade auch wieder für ein Buchprojekt damit beschäftigt. Und du kannst wirklich so viele Geschichten über diesen Verein erzählen, weil er einfach so eine bewegte Vergangenheit hat, weil es ihn einfach auch schon so lange gibt. Aber es ist eine unfassbare Bürde. Es baut Druck auf, es baut Begehrlichkeiten auf. Und das Publikum in Lautern ist halt so, es gibt Himmel noch jauchzend und zu Tode betrübt. Also es ist entweder schwarz oder weiß. Es ist Jubel, Trubel, Heiterkeit oder alle sind tief traurig. Also es ist einfach so, sobald die anfangen wieder einigermaßen Fußball zu spielen, dann träumen alle wieder. Und dieses ganze Umfeld, wer das Stadion gesehen hat, und wir haben auch, ihr habt auch darüber gesprochen, wie viele Fans auf die Auswärtsspiele kommen und so. Es ist natürlich von diesem Drumherum, von der Fanbase, vom Stadion und so, ist es Erstligalike. Ja, da müssen wir nicht drüber streiten. Das ist Fakt, auch von den Zuschauerzahlen her. Aber man muss auch sagen, dieses große Gebild der FCK, mit allem, was dranhängt, mit den Finanzen und so weiter und so fort, kommt aus den Drittliga-Jahren. Da hat man die Struktur komplett runtergefahren. Und quasi dieses Stadion hat noch existiert, aber alles drunter war halt eher Drittliganiveau. Es ist jetzt teilweise immer noch, weil man erst langsam diese Strukturen wieder aufbaut. Von daher langsam wieder aufbauen und dann, sage ich mal, ab nächstem Jahr vielleicht...
Nein, nein, das ist ja schon total falsch. Also, sorry, aber jetzt mal ein kurzer Reality-Check. Rohergebnis, erste FC Kaiserslautern, Saison 21-22. Das sind die letzten Zahlen, die wir von der DFL haben. Das, was man eingenommen hat, 19 Millionen Euro. 19 fucking Millionen Euro. Ich predige in der Bundesliga-Männer-Sendung immer, dass du als Aufsteiger irgendwie versuchen musst, 100 Mio zu reißen, dann kannst du in der Liga bleiben. Jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was hatte denn Darmstadt 98, 26 Millionen? Klingt nicht, ist immer noch viel, viel weniger. Aber prozentual ein Riesenunterschied. Was hatte Heidenheim schon doppelt so viel? 39 Millionen. Was hat der VfL-Buch rum? Warte, ich habe es nur gerade rausgesucht. 63 Millionen Euro. Das sind andere Dimensionen. Natürlich kann ein Wunder geschehen, und du kannst mal aufsteigen. Aber es ist nicht wahrscheinlich, selbst wenn du es nachhaltig machen kannst, es ist nicht wahrscheinlich. Und dass Fans nicht so denken, das soll ja auch immer so sein. Ich würde als Fan auch nicht so denken wollen. Und als ich noch Fan war, habe ich auch nicht so gedacht. Das ist ja fürchterlich. Das ist ja schlecht für die Seele. Aber Verantwortungsträger dürfen doch dem nicht erliegen. Und die dürfen doch dann auch nicht einfach einen Trainer rauswerfen.
Nein, das Problem ist, oder eins der vielen Probleme ist, du hast zum Beispiel auch diese Situation, weil wir jetzt gerade auch beim Thema Finanzen sind, der FCK ist ja nur Mieter im eigenen Stadion. Und diese Geschichte wird dir halt immer weiterhin zum Verhängnis werden, weil es, und das sagt die Vereinführung auch, dass du dieses Ding nur dann wirtschaftlich betreiben kannst, eigentlich, wenn du in der ersten Liga spielst. Die sind jetzt mittlerweile dran, da auch einen neuen Pachtvertrag auszuhandeln, aber da gibt es, glaube ich, noch viel zu tun. Und deswegen ist es einfach so, das ist das, was ich meine, dieses Konstrukt ist jetzt das falsche Wort, der FCK ist alles andere als ein Konstrukt, aber die Struktur ist ungesund und deswegen ist man so ein bisschen verdammt dazu, erfolgreicher zu sein und aufzusteigen.
Ja, okay, das verstehe ich. Aber das heißt, ihr habt aktuell einen Heimsschnitt von rund 43.000 Zuschauern. Das würde jetzt nicht reichen, um die Miete zu bezahlen für diese Stade.
Das reicht dann mittlerweile schon, aber man muss sich das immer so vorstellen, das hören jetzt, glaube ich, auch einige Stadion-Romantiker nicht gerne, die den Betzenberg über alles lieben. Betzenberg ist ein tolles Stadion, das wird zwar das Stadion, keine Frage. Es ist aber sehr in die Jahre gekommen. Dieses Stadion, da muss sehr, sehr, sehr viel Geld reingesteckt werden, jedes Jahr, damit da der Laden läuft. Ich habe die Zeit jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber allein schon, wenn dieses Stadion auch nur aufgeschlossen wird, wie viele 10.000 Euro das kostet. Es ist immer noch ein tolles Stadion, aber es kostet einfach unglaublich viel Geld, dass es diesen Ist-Zustand erhalten kann. Wenn wir da jetzt einsteigen wollen, Thema Umsatz, Thema Finanzen in der ersten Liga, es ist jetzt auch schon so, dass die VIP-Tickets quasi auf Jahre hinweg mehr oder weniger vergriffen sind. Es gibt zu wenig VIP-Plätze, es gibt zu wenig logische Plätze. Da müsstest du irgendwie nochmal nachbessern in der ersten Liga. Da ist da sicherlich auch nochmal ein bisschen mehr gefragt. Da gibt es zwar auch noch Potenzial, aber es ist einfach so, das Ding kostet Geld und dementsprechend ist es dann einfach schwierig, das irgendwie wirtschaftlich zu betreiben. Aber ja, das, was du gesagt hast, da gebe ich dir auch recht. Und was da ja dazu kommt, du hast ein paar Kennzahlen jetzt genannt, aber diese Schere zwischen den Vereinen, die jetzt auch, sage ich mal, nicht erst zwei, drei, sondern vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, zehn Jahre plus Bundesliga spielen und dem FCK, der jetzt gerade aus Drittliga-Zeiten kommt und jetzt gerade mal das zweite Jahr Zweite Liga spielt, ist so unfassbar groß und die wird ja von Jahr zu Jahr größer. Selbst wenn du jetzt nicht mehr noch mal runtergehst in die Dritte Liga, sondern dich in der Zweiten Liga etablierst. Das ist ja, ich meine, guckt euch an, was mit den Aufsteigern passiert. Du hast auch den einen oder anderen Namen schon genannt. Die können, selbst wenn die dann teilweise den doppelten Umsatz haben als die Konkurrenz, also für die ist es genauso schwer. Guckt euch Darmstadt an, guckt euch Heidenheim an. Das ist ja so. Wenn du dann hochgehst, dann ist das oft halt einfach so ein Kurzausflug. Kevin nimmt auch schon die Kader.
Du musst dich ja quasi in der Zweiten Liga etablieren. Und da ist doch gerade Lautern gut dabei. Ihr habt es doch schon, einer von euch weiß gerade nicht mehr, wer es gesagt hat. Ihr habt ja schon gesagt, Braunschweig und Osnabrück. 8 Punkte und 7 Punkte. Genau, Kevin hat es gesagt. Das ist ja das große Pfund gerade für alle, für die es gerade darum geht, in dieser Liga zu bleiben. 10 Punkte Vorsprung hat der FCK. Und ich verstehe schon, dass einem da die Muffen gehen, wenn man dann so eine schlechte Serie hat und so weiter und so fort. Aber es ist doch alles noch gerade wunderbar. Und das Ziel muss es doch erst mal sein, jetzt 5 Jahre Zweite Liga zu spielen.
Ich muss sogar auch ganz provokant noch dazu sagen, nicht nur Braunschweig und Osnabrück. Ich schaue da auch ganz, ganz intensiv auf Schalke. Weil ja, es tut mir leid. Ich kenne auch viele Schalke-Fans sehr, sehr gut. Aber ich kann aus eigener Erfahrung sprechen, wie schnell man dann abrutscht. Oder abrutschen kann, diese Gefahr dann auch mal durchgereicht zu werden. Ich habe am Anfang der Saison auch gedacht, oh, die Hertha muss ich auch mal umschauen. Die haben sich jetzt mittlerweile stark gefangen, aber die haben auch, muss man sagen, ein Kader, der alles andere als abstiegshaufig ist. Ja, aber ich würde es mir auf jeden Fall wünschen, dass Schalke definitiv in der Liga bleibt, bzw. sich fängt und wieder weiter oben angreift. Aber es ist verdammt schwer, wenn du mal wirklich da unten drin steckst, da auch wieder rauszukommen. Der FCK hat es erlebt, dann geht es ruckzuck, und dann bist du auf einmal in dieser dritten Liga. Und da dann wieder rauszukommen, bock schwer.
Wir haben es auch erlebt damals.
Wie ist der Trainer damals, der die strömenden Wetter euch noch gerettet hat am 34. Spieltag im Fritz-Walter-Wetter? Wer war der Trainer noch mal, Sebastian?
Damals, 2008, meinst du? Gegen Köln?
Ja, genau.
Milan Zasic, meinst du Milan Zasic?
Ja, Milan Zasic, genau. Ich habe noch gedacht, es regelt. Fritz-Walter-Wetter. Ich habe das damals auf der Autobahn gehört, zwischen Augsburg und München.
Mir fällt bei Kaiserslautern immer nur Olaf Marsal an.
Olaf Nagenpflaster Marsal.
Ich kann mich da noch genau dran erinnern. Ich habe das im Radio gehört, natürlich. Der Kommentator hat die Frage gestellt, Herr Zasic, als es vorhin angefangen hat zu regnen, haben Sie da auch gedacht, Fritz-Walter-Wetter. Da dachte ich mir noch, das ist aber eine komische Frage. Und dann sagt Milan Zasic, da sagen Sie was, genau das. Ich habe gesagt, das ist unsere Hütte. Und ich dachte mir so, okay, geile Frage, muss ich mir merken.
Er war ja auch damals, hat er einige Schlagzeilen gemacht, als er die Mannschaft in die Kurve geschickt hat. Und sie hat sie quasi dazu gezwungen, sich auspfeifen zu lassen nach einer Niederlage. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, gegen wen das war. Aber das war quasi mitten im Abstiegskampf. Und er hat die Mannschaft vor die Kurve zitiert. Die mussten sich da 5, 6 Minuten richtig beschimpfen lassen.
Es war nicht alles gut unter Ihnen.
Ich wollte sehen, dass Sie sehen diese Verzweiflung in die Auge. Also ich kann es nicht so gut nachmachen. Aber das war schon auch ein spezieller Typ. Aber ja, um darauf nochmal zurückzukommen, 2. Liga, ich persönlich finde ja auch rein von den Namen her, und das sage ich jetzt wirklich nicht, weil ich Reporter und Richterstatter über die 2. Liga bin, ich finde die 2. Liga viel geiler als die Bundesliga. Rein von den Namen her und von den Clubs her.
Es geht mir tatsächlich fast ähnlich so diese Saison. Es ist ganz extrem dieses Jahr, wie sehr mein Interesse sich ein bisschen stärker nochmals auf die 2. Liga verlagert hat.
Das ist schon krass. Außer das Einzige, was ich dieses Jahr spannend finde, ist, ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr über die Bundesliga reden, aber was Leverkusen diese Saison auf dem Platz zaubert, ist schon ganz nett anzusehen. Aber ich gucke tatsächlich auch sehr wenig.
Die haben wirklich schön weit gegen uns gespielt im Pokal. Also da hast du richtig gesehen, ohne abdriften zu wollen, dass die wirklich einfach umschalten konnten. Also wir haben das 1-2 gemacht und haben sich gedacht, ach ja, jetzt müssen wir doch noch mal kurz ein paar Minuten Gas geben. Man ist 3-1 vier Minuten später. Dann haben sie wieder runtergefahren, haben wir das 2-3 gemacht. Das war dann abseits und dann war das Spiel vorbei. Und vorher, also das 1-0 von dem, wie heißt er, Boniface. Unfassbar. Unser Innenverteidiger klebt an ihm. Und der macht das Ding trotzdem so was von easy mit dem Inneres weg.
Ich finde, es lohnt sich allein schon wegen der Trainingsvideos, wenn man dann Xabi Alonso sieht, wie alt ist er mittlerweile. Keine Ahnung, immer noch die Bälle da zentimetergenau in der Mitte seiner Schützen gespielt.
Und wie sympathisch der auf der Pressekonferenz auch rüberkommt. Das sind in meinen romantischen Erinnerungen auch an früher diese weltmännischen Typen, die einem völlig unterlegenen Gegner immer noch was Gutes zusprechen können. Und wirklich sportsmännisch darumlaufen. Oder wie nennt man das jetzt? Ich weiß nicht, Max, sagt man noch sportsmännisch? Ich weiß nicht. Ein Gentleman, so würde man auch gesagt.
Böse Zungen könnten uns jetzt vorwerfen und behaupten, wir reden jetzt nur so gut über Leverkusen, weil keiner die im Pokal als Gegner haben will.
Ja, bitte nicht.
Ich mag das los, auch maximal Kacke.
Ihr wart ja auch in Freiburg, müsstet ja schon auswärts ran.
Da hatten wir ja zuerst ein Spiel in Berlin bei der Hertha, dann ging es nach Freiburg und dann nach Karlsruhe. Wir hatten also drei Auswärtsspiele in einer Woche. Das war toll. Und was für Distanzen. Wenn du da als Fan mitgereist bist komplett, hast du ein paar Tausend Kilometer drauf gehabt.
Wir warten jetzt allerdings auch seit rund fünf Jahren auf ein Heimspiel im Pokal. Das ist wirklich ein großes Thema in Düsseldorf. Wir hoffen auf ein Heimspiel und bitte nicht Stuttgart oder Freiburg.
Auf Freiburg fahren wir jetzt immer wieder gerne.
Lass mich noch ganz kurz, weil wir jetzt ein bisschen abgeschweift sind. Es ging ja eigentlich auch mal um den Trainer und so weiter. Ich möchte gerne eine Sache auf jeden Fall noch kurz loswerden, die einfach auffällig ist und die mir einfach wichtig ist, anzusprechen. Ich hatte ja angedeutet, dass ich der Meinung bin, dass Dimitrios Kamotsos wahrscheinlich nicht die 1A-Lösung war. Und so ist es halt bei vielen Fans auch angekommen. Und für viele Fans ist er halt nach wie vor auch nicht die Wunschbesetzung, sozusagen. Und es war sehr bedenklich zu sehen, was dann da erzählt und geschrieben wurde und behauptet wurde und gegrüllt wurde. Also eigentlich hat der arme Mann von Anfang an schon verloren gehabt, weil mehr oder weniger die Hälfte aller Leute ihn gar nicht haben wollten. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft das bei anderen Vereinen schon so war, wenn irgendwo ein neuer Trainer kam, dass da wirklich so eine große Antipathie herrschte. Hängt natürlich auch damit zusammen, dass viele immer noch Anhänger von Dirk Schuster waren und natürlich nicht damit einverstanden waren, dass er da entlassen wurde. Aber was da dann teilweise abgesondert wurde, auch in den einschlägigen Fonds und so weiter, das ist schon grenzwertig. Ich meine, ich verstehe, dass das Leute vielleicht enttäuscht sind, aber ich finde, das Mindeste, was ein Trainer verdient hat, ist, dass er zumindest die Chance bekommt, mal anzukommen und einfach mal zu zeigen, dass er vielleicht auch das Vertrauen der sportlichen Führung verdient hat. Wenn das dann nicht bringt, dann können ihn die Leute immer noch auspfeifen und rausrufen. Das ist so, ist das Geschäft halt. Aber was tut man seinem Verein und seiner Mannschaft für einen Gefallen, wenn man den Trainer von Anfang an so in Frage stellt? Also das ist einfach, ja, fand ich sehr, sehr bedenklich. Und von daher hat er jetzt natürlich, kann man sagen, direkt schon eine Antwort gegeben mit dem Sieg im Pokal. Jetzt warten wir mal ab. Ich habe auch gesagt, für mich eigentlich so schön das ist, im Pokal da auch weiterzukommen und vielleicht je nach Los, die Chance zu haben, dass es diese Saison auch mal echt relativ weit geht im Pokal. Das Kerngeschäft ist und bleibt die Liga. Also wenn ich, wenn, ich glaube, wenn die meisten Leute sich jetzt aussuchen könnten, wo der FCK seine Spiele gewinnt, dann würden sie auch die Liga nehmen. Und da stehen jetzt wirklich nochmal ein paar harte Spiele bevor. Jetzt kommen im Samstag Heimspiel gegen Hertha. Das wird alles andere als einfach. Die sind auch richtig gut drauf. Ich habe echt ein bisschen Angst vor Reze, muss ich sagen. Was der im Moment spielt.
Aber der wird viel rotieren, hat er schon gesagt.
Ja, aber den rotiert er bestimmt nicht raus. Und dann tatsächlich auch noch in Braunschweig, auch wenn die Tabelle es anders vermuten lässt, aber das musste er auch erstmal gewinnen. Und dann schauen wir mal, wie es nach der Winter- oder wie man dann zur Winterpause steht. Von daher, aber ja, wie gesagt, das mit Kramozis wollte ich einfach mal loswerden, weil das einfach...
Er kann nichts dafür und das ist sowieso... Also Hate Speech generell muss man sich sparen. Meine Güte, das war der längste 2. Liga-Kurzpass diese Saison. Gut, dass du gesagt hast, Sebastian, dass du raus musstest. Das haben wir ja ganz fantastisch...
Haben wir super geschafft...
.bekommen. Ich erspare euch jetzt die Quoten zum Spiel Nürnberg gegen Lautern. Die sprechen nämlich gegen stärkste 2. Liga aller Zeiten und so weiter. Das ist leider... Ich sehe das auch so, dass viele Vereine da einen Reiz haben, die mancher Erstligist nicht erfüllt. Quoten und auch Sponsoren und sonstige Ausgaben sprechen, aber leider klar gegen diese These. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Auf meinen Lesungen wird das häufiger gesagt von Leuten, die sagen, die 2. Liga ist doch viel besser, viel weniger langweilig als die 1. Liga. Ich habe ja irgendwie so 30 Lesungen gemacht. Jetzt habe ich bestimmt 8-10 Mal diese Frage. Dann habe ich irgendwann angefangen, zurückzufangen, sag mir mal die ersten 3 in der 2. Liga. Einmal wurde es beantwortet. Ansonsten wussten diejenigen, die gesagt haben, die 2. Liga ist viel geiler, als die 1. wussten es nicht. Konnten mir aber alles erzählen über Boniface, über Bayern und über Dortmund. Interzic hat keine Ahnung, weil er muss Chan nicht immer so zurückziehen in die Abwehr und so. Es ist leider in der Realität ein bisschen anders, als man es fühlt. Aber weil wir auch quasi noch diese Gefühle für diese Vereine haben, mit denen wir aufgewachsen sind. Kinder der 90er, 80er. Ja, so ist es eben. Den Reality-Check muss man dann auch bei sich selbst machen. Jetzt mache ich aber den Clock-Check und sage, das muss jetzt wirklich reichen, auch wenn ich mit euch allen drei noch ewig hätte weiterreden können. Ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt das Gefühl, ihr hättet mich gar nicht gebraucht, so wie das hier zwischendurch lief. Vielleicht gehe ich einfach pennen und ihr macht das hier alleine fertig. Also wirklich ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. So ist das, wenn man mit Podcast-Profis aufnimmt. Das hat Riesenfreude gemacht. Herzlichen Dank an Kevin Bublitz. Ich werde den Padercast verlinken. Alle hören jetzt rein. Danke dir, Kevin, dass du mal wieder hier warst.
Danke auch für die Einladung. Immer wieder gerne.
Ja, und danke an Thorsten Wiese. Ein sensationelles Debüt. Ich wünschte, ich wäre bei meinem ersten Podcast-Auftritt, der leider auch noch zu finden ist, im Netz so souverän gewesen. Danke, Thorsten. Von gebrabbelrot-weiß wird natürlich auch verlinkt. Danke, dass du hier warst.
Ja, vielen lieben Dank für die Einladung, Max. Hat mich super gefreut.
Und wer noch mehrere Stunden von Sebastian Zobel hören möchte, der kann bei Nurder FCK reinhören und der kann im Rasenfunk reinhören. Ich werde noch mal die entsprechenden Tribüngespräche verlinken. Sebastian, danke dir, dass du, obwohl du so einen Titan-Terminplan morgen früh hast, darf man da überhaupt nur früh sagen, oder ist das noch nachts? Also gefühlt ist es noch nachts.
Ich werde von dir träumen heute Nacht, Max. In den wenigen Stunden, die mir noch bleiben.
Ja, meine Güte, es ist ein Drama. Also vielen Dank, dass du hier warst.
Ich danke dir, Max.
Ja, das kann ich nur so zurückgeben. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbungsponsorenfrei. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und was kauft ihr leer? Genau, kiosk.rasenfunk.de kauft ihr leer. Kauf die Tasse für Mutti. Das ist das neue Hashtag zu dieser Sendung. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Empfehlt den Rasenfunk weiter. Bleibt uns gewogen, bleibt dran. Auf rasenfunk.de gibt es noch viele Sendungen mehr. Und bleibt vor allem gesund. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.